hablemos de los territorios insurales e
insulares concretamente de las Islas
turcas jamaica y Santa Lucía que
registran las tasas más altas de
homicidios porque el Caribe se convirtió
en una zona crítica cuéntenos
Pues sí muchos países del Caribe
registran tasas de homicidios muy
superiores a la media el resto de
América Latina que a su vez son muy
superiores a la media mundial nuestra
región es por desgracia las más
mortíferas del mundo internos de las
Naciones caribeños la dinámica de la
violencia está vinculada con las bandas
Las Bandas y las venganzas son
responsables de gran parte de los
asesinatos la fácil disponibilidad de
armas de fuego es otro factor importante
y por supuesto Siempre hay el tráfico de
drogas
Qué otros factores conectan estos
patrones de violencia en toda la región
Pues
el gran motor de de homicidios y del del
abuso sistemático de Derechos Humanos es
el narcotráfico eso es generar violencia
y cuando estudiamos los países donde
había aumentos Grandes como Ecuador uno
ve a su raíz el narcotráfico
principalmente de cocaína Hablemos
concretamente del Ecuador país cuya tasa
de homicidios tuvo un aumento
significativo Qué factores impulsaron
esta escala violenta
totalmente relacionado con con el
tráfico de drogas dos de los
departamentos colombianos con más
producción de cocaína nariño y putumayo
se encuentran en la frontera con Ecuador
junta con muchos facciones enfrentadas
entre ellos la ex farmacia o disidentes
la cocaína procedente tanto de Colombia
como de Perú tránsita por Ecuador
especialmente por el puerto de Guayaquil
lo que ha provocado el desarrollo
acelerado de la delincuencia organizada
ecuatoriana y ahora bandas criminales
rivales luchan entre sí por el control
de esta lucrativo negocio trabajando
principalmente con narcotraficantes
colombianos y mexicanos
entonces Colombia y Perú pueden que haya
sufrido la misma situación también
pues Colombia históricamente ha tenido
niveles de homicidios muy altos gracias
No solo al narcotráfico para el
conflicto civil en los últimos años a a
un descenso que gracias en gran parte el
acuerdo de paz con a con las Farc y
también el narcotráfico en Colombia ha
llegado a la a la conclusión que es
mucho mejor la plata Que el plomo y los
narcotraficantes invisibles prefieren
usar corrupción no violencia para
facilitar su negocio